las fuerzas medidas de bioseguridad por
el coronavirus no ralentizaron el ritmo
de las votaciones en ecuador la jornada
electoral dio comienzo a las siete de la
mañana con 12,6 millones de ecuatorianos
llamados a las urnas en territorio
nacional y 13,1 millones desde el
extranjero la segunda ronda de las
presidenciales marcadas por la pandemia
y la grave crisis económica que
atraviesa el país esperamos un nuevo
gobernante para que venga a reactivar
nuestra economía nuestra salud nuestra
educación con esa esperanza estamos aquí
en la en la fila los ecuatorianos por un
nuevo ecuador poco después del mediodía
al 45 34 por ciento de los electores
habían ejercido su derecho al voto según
el consejo nacional electoral en juego
están dos modelos opuestos de país este
domingo la presidencia ecuatoriana se
debate entre el conservador neoliberal
guillermo lasso y el sucesor del
correísmo andrés zarautz con la figura
del ex presidente rafael correa la
sombra por el momento estamos en una
corrupción total
espero
el quien entre sepa gobernar
adecuadamente como futuros no solamente
para ellos sino para todo el país en
general los sondeos pronostican una
reñida contienda donde el dividido voto
indígena será crucial luego de que en
primera vuelta sonarán las acusaciones
de fraude por el ex candidato del
movimiento indígena ya cooper que lo que
diga el pueblo sea lo que lo que se
pronuncie que sea la verdad en una
fraude de los lobbies pero ecuador vive
desde 2019 una dura crisis financiera
agravada con la pandemia de kobe 19 el
candidato ganador deberá hacer frente
ahora a la tercera ola de la enfermedad